lot of transs you know I always see that
in the paper about somebody who has
switched their sex which I'm all if
that's what makes you that what blows
your dress up all the way
yes fat bad oh
bad be who you are yes claps I think
there's some uh money to be made in some
sort of exchange with everyone switching
if you need a penis take a penis if you
have a penis give a penis I feel like if
there was some exchange uh maybe Bitcoin
could be involved and you could you know
no I just don't like joking about oh
Bella oh for fake what a shame she also
says something that I think is kind of
interesting just like be who you are
just as if well if you wanted to be who
you are you'd be like well look at that
that's what I
am